para su proyecto de último año ricardo
está investigando cuánto dinero un
universitario graduado puede esperar
ganar basándose en su especialidad
encuentra los siguientes datos
interesantes
la estrella de básquetbol michael jordan
era un licenciado en geología en la
universidad de carolina del norte sólo
había tres ingenieros civiles en la
universidad de montana todos tomaron
exactamente el mismo trabajo en la misma
compañía con el mismo salario de los 35
licenciados en finanzas de la
universidad de west lei en 32 obtuvieron
empleos de consultoría con un alto
salario y los otros tres estaban
desempleados para los licenciados en
geología de la universidad de carolina
del norte el ingreso mediano
probablemente será y tenemos varias
opciones aquí menor que igual a o mayor
que el promedio y luego tenemos que
responder la misma pregunta para
ingenieros civiles de montana el ingreso
mediano
de hecho ambos hablan de la mediana el
ingreso mediano va a ser y lo comparamos
con el promedio para licenciados en
finanzas de web player vamos a comparar
el ingreso mediano con el promedio para
visualizar esto un poco más copie este
mismo problema en mi cuaderno de apuntes
y aquí está
y ahora puedo escribir en esto pensemos
en cada uno de estos
a los licenciados y geología de la
universidad de carolina del norte el
ingreso mediano va a ser
y cómo puedo comparar el promedio qué es
lo que nos dicen de la uc l nos dicen
que michael jordan era un licenciado en
geología en la universidad de carolina
del norte así que como se podría ver la
distribución de salarios si estamos
pensando en la universidad de carolina
del norte probablemente se vería algo
así
y voy a hacer una distribución muy burda
por aquí
y digamos que este salario este va a ser
un salario de 0
y digamos que este es un salario de
no lo sé déjame pongo un salario de 50
mil aquí
haré esto en miles digamos que este es
cien mil
justo aquí y luego tenemos a michael
jordan que es y déjame poco un espacio
aquí porque está demasiado arriba no sé
exactamente lo que estaba haciendo pero
definitivamente estaba en los 10
millones de dólares al año por lo que
michael jordan está muy muy muy por
arriba así que si hicieras un listo
grama una gráfica de todos los salarios
dirías
está bien quizás tendríamos a si
contamos a todos los geólogos de la
universidad de carolina del norte
probablemente especialmente después de
graduarse habrá probablemente
23 y podría seguir con un gran número de
personas que ganan 50 mil algunas
personas que ganando un poco más quizá
algunas personas aquí
tal vez algunas personas acá
unas acá
otras acá
tal vez alguien está ganando 100 mil
o tal vez hay algunos cuantos acá
tal vez alguien no está ganando nada tal
vez no pudieron encontrar trabajo y
luego tienes a michael jordan por acá
arriba haciendo 10 millones 20 millones
o un valor parecido cuando estás en una
situación así donde tienes este dato tan
separado que es michael jordan va a
afectar bastante el promedio no va a
afectar la mediana porque recuerden la
mediana es el valor medio así que no
importa qué tan grande es este número
puedes hacer este un trillón de dólares
y no va a cambiar al valor medio el
valor medio aún va a ser el mismo valor
medio puedes mover esto a cualquier
lugar alrededor de este rango y no va a
cambiar la mediana
pero el promedio si cambia si esto se
vuelve muy muy elevado va a distorsionar
al promedio actual así que para los
licenciados en geología de la ucm el
ingreso mediano va a ser menor que el
promedio porque michael jordan está
elevando el promedio y dejarlo
seleccionar
así que para licenciados en geología de
la ucm la mediana va a ser menor que el
promedio ahora pensemos en las demás
para ingenieros civiles de montaña el
ingreso mediano va a ser espacio el
promedio nos dicen que sólo había tres
ingenieros civiles de la universidad de
montana y todos ellos tienen exactamente
el mismo trabajo en la misma compañía
ganando el mismo salario digamos que los
tres ganan cincuenta mil dólares
digamos que ese es su salario entonces
tienes si fueras a calcular el promedio
sería cincuenta
más
50 más
50 entre 3
que por supuesto sería
al promedio si quisieras calcular la
mediana enlista los salarios en orden
y luego tomas el de en medio y el de en
medio es 50 en este caso la mediana es
igual al promedio así que seleccionemos
eso la mediana
es igual al promedio
y finalmente déjame volver a mi cuaderno
de apuntes para especialistas en
finanzas de weasley en el ingreso
mediano va a ser espacio el promedio
así que pensemos en esta distribución de
aquí aquí tenemos que de los 35 32
obtuvieron empleos de consultoría con
salarios elevados así que digamos que
ganan que ganan cerca de 100 mil por lo
que la distribución se verá algo así
donde este es un cero y este es digamos
que este es 50.000
digamos que este de aquí
en mil dólares al año así que 32
obtuvieron empleos de consultoría de
salarios elevados tienes
1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11 12 13 14 15
7 18 19 20 21 22 23 24 26 27 28 29 30 31
32 así que la distribución para la gente
que obtuvo los empleos podría verse algo
así pero hubo tres personas desempleadas
por lo que no tienen ingresos y son uno
dos y tres ahora aquí tienes tres
valores separados como en el caso de
michael jordan pero en lugar de que sean
muy grandes son muy pequeños así que van
a disminuir el promedio no van a si
estos fueran cero si éstos fueran 50 o
si éstos estuvieran por aquí no van a
afectar a la mediana el número medio aún
va a ser el mismo pero van a disminuir
el promedio así que aquí yo diría que el
ingreso mediano será probablemente más
alto será probablemente mayor que el
promedio porque el promedio va a
disminuir por estos valores separados
estas tres personas que no están ganando
nada así que tenemos ese cuadro para los
licenciados de finanzas de weasley en el
ingreso mediano probablemente será mayor
que el promedio
comprobemos nuestra respuesta la tuvimos
bien